what's up hot breath averse welcome back
this is comedians on skype talking
comedy presented by the hot breath
comedy network if you're watching this
on YouTube welcome to the show just know
that to get involved in these live Q&A s
and ask your own questions you have to
go join our Facebook group that is
linked in the description but without
further ado today's guest is one of hot
breaths favorite he did episode 194 way
back in the dizzay and now he is back to
answer all your most valuable questions
please welcome to the show
Mike Vicki own everyone welcome to the
show Mike Vicki own good thanks for you
got a haircut during this quarantine how
did you do that yeah I've been violating
the rules I've been doing my own thing
how have you been I like to start all
these off with like you're frozen I'm
frozen no keys it keeps freezing very
you think it keeps freezing oh yeah
you're freezing I must be freezing
who is freezing you are freezing here
back now I'm freezing in my back people
watching how are we doing oh no yeah
are we alright no froze again a little
bit don't do your back your back we're
back okay we're gonna make this work
here despite so skip says we're both
freezing maybe far but we're getting
likes we're getting engagement
let's hope maybe the freezing is helping
maybe the whole thing is freezing he
says that's so we just did an hour and
everything you're good now Dave mamrie
says her name REE
so we'll just roll with it and we'll
hope for the best here good now they're
saying okay okay so yeah I always like
to open these up with just asking about
what what this quarantine and how it's
affected your comedy and how you're
trying to like maximize your quote
downtime or free time right now and
maybe tips you have for how comics can
really make the most of what seems like
a bad situation how can we make this
like a good opportunity okay I know
everybody's different so keep that in
mind I'm just gonna tell you what I do
what I've been doing is I'm up I am the
guy who gets on stage a lot because I
live in New York so it's been a huge and
I've been on the road a lot too so it's
a huge drop-off first of all but it took
me like I was kind of overworked anyway
like running around the city and then
being on the road and then so I was kind
of rundown so I just took like some time
plus you have to adjust to the
quarantine I to get stuff like food and
toilet paper and all that so I didn't do
anything for like a week but then once
we settled in I started on it just as
just the normal of Anila advice that
they give everybody which is like keep a
schedule so I've been doing that not you
know waking up whatever I wake up having
coffee
I meditate meditate coffee and then
either a workout or journal and then and
then a workout and then and then lunch
and then as the day goes by I I kind of
like I try to use my energy earlier in
the day is what I'm trying to say
because there's no spots at night so
right trying to wake up but I'm not
really writing jokes in the sense like
turning out material because there's no
where to try it out so I'm just mostly
journaling yeah that's what I've been
finding too is I'm more of like in I'm
almost more in like getting organized
mode or planning mode and more of just
trying to get all my ducks in a row I
haven't really been doing joke writing
but I have been doing journaling and
trying to maybe build more of a strategy
around what I'm doing as opposed to
getting and we get in that mode of write
jokes perform write jokes perform but
I'm using this time too
- start think about what else can I do
when I don't have the performance outlet
right there's also podcasting I have a
podcast called no disrespect so with
justice silver and so what I do is I'll
prepare for that the way I've always
prepared for it which is it's a it's
more of a joke based on cast so I'll
prepare for whatever topics we're going
to do or whatever segments we have
planned but even that's an adjustment
cuz went on the studio some known that's
an adjustment but try to plan for that
that's joke writing but other than that
it's journaling and then there's
different strategies with the journal
it's like yeah you journal and then take
notes on the side of the journal this
could be something this could be
something this could be something and
then and then I read it into a recorder
and then listening to it back when I
take a walk huh you know to see it's
kind of like listening to a set until
they're just we're all of thoughts you
know the process is a little different
because you try to this might be
something and then maybe take that and
work with out a little bit or that's a
good idea or because there's a million
funny things that happen to you every
day even in this situation but it's just
a matter of identifying them and then
taking them out we don't always have the
presence of mind to write the stuff down
on our phone and so if you journal you
know once a day or once every two days
and they and then make notes and then
read it into your phone and then listen
to it back it keeps it like fresh oh
that was fine oh that was something cuz
I find the problem is that we forget
stuff so fast I finally think it
happening or a potential thing cavaness
really funny and you'll just forget
about it you'll just go on in your life
especially now nobody's performing
interesting so when you're journaling is
it more like is it like well I'm waking
up at 7 a.m. and you kind of just start
whatever's top of mind or do you have
more of a plan behind the journaling now
I you're just what happened in your day
or what happened yesterday and then and
then if you really think about it
because it's still kind still pretty
fresh in your mind if you really think
about each thing that happened to you
it's not just about each thing it's not
just about documenting the thing it's
also which I've learned is uh your
feelings about it are funny you know I
mean were there's a lot of stuff that
could have happened you know what if
this or what if that and and your
feelings towards that and and and as you
know there's different things that could
have happened what your feelings we
their check so it's important that
that's like an important thing instead
of just documenting everything oh that's
funny
adding an emotional connection to what
you're talking about that's fascinating
right and that makes whatever jokes that
you're making it makes it numb number
one more organic and then it makes it it
makes it rich but you can still use your
joke writing ability that's what I've
learned like it makes it because more
often than not people have had other
people if you've experienced it other
people have experienced it and they're
going to go oh yeah so you're gonna have
that identification factor and then you
use your joke writing ability to turn it
on it and then it extrapolates out and
and it's it could make it funny oh very
nice and this actually ties into the
first the first question here from skip
on gel or angel I don't I don't know he
always attends these q and A's but I'm
not quite sure how to say his last name
but I asked ya hey skips yeah Mike said
hey oh that's great so his is a great
question and what I loved about your
interview with us when you were in
Atlanta we did last year was just like
and Nate said this in his Q&A he's like
you're just like a craftsman he put you
on like an at L level and I've heard me
Bert Kreischer like all the top comics
you're known as like the joke crafts
hello I think we're still here I think
we're still in the current one okay
that's so crazy and you know it was skip
says his question broke the video but
that's what yeah the Sean well we did
one with Sean Patton yeah about like 30
minutes in the Internet like dropped and
we had to do the rest
on the phone but we're back on this one
so okay let's get to the question here
it's skip asks what's a writing exercise
or discipline you use frequently I try
to do I used to sit down and write
before sets like just trying to churn
out jokes individual jokes but I found
that to be it was I can see that you
know you do something and then you see
the result of it so my first owl like
that's what I did and then I listened to
the album it's like great jokes but okay
on the next one I would like to have
great jokes but I would like it to be
more organic so in order for that to
happen you have to change your process
which is instead of just joke writing
I'm gonna still joke right but I'm gonna
journal now and then I'm gonna take the
organic situations that happen in my
life and I'll apply my joke writing
ability to that instead of just trying
to sit down and grind out jokes
I need a marriage joke I need a gambling
joke I need a something so it's like I
used to do that we need a marriage joke
a gambling trip it's sex joke I need
this and instead now it's just like okay
what's happening in your life take it
write it and then apply the joke writing
your strategy to to what's already
happening
Oh so instead of trying to yeah find
material you almost look at what's
already easily accessible to you and
write it from there
right that Comedy Cellar show Beauty
topics and they're like okay here's the
topics and that's kind of the challenge
because it's like okay we're all doing
like these are the topics what can you
find you know and then it's a different
it's now it's like look at the angles
what are some of the angles and then I
don't really journal on that I just look
at the angles and then maybe there's
something here maybe there's something
here maybe there's something here and
because it has to be taped in a timely
fashion how video what my thoughts are
on it video my thoughts and now watch it
and be like oh maybe there's something
there I can tighten up something there I
can much like I said there's something
there I can tighten up that's an idea
but not ready that's not done and then
and then keep shooting it until I crap
the points that I want and it helps you
what helps me
you'll write you'll write a joke and
then record yourself doing it and refine
it that way yep you have a topic and
then I'll go okay what are the what are
the angles here on this and and I'll
write the angles and then try to do a
cohesive video of it like a video just
for myself because you're going on stage
that night so it's like huh and you in
you maybe you got the you got the topics
the day before so there's no time so
it's just like you're taking all right
kids we're back okay we're back here so
what I just did is I just connected my
computer to my phone's internet so just
no hot breath we're draining the data
for this one we're using the whole data
plan to get this interview but I think
we're good now actually so this is gonna
be great my mom my mom will be thrilled
I used up all her data don't worry so
what it kind of cut out a little bit
that is interesting I didn't know this
Comedy Cellar show did that though to
where it was like okay here are your
topics you have a day to write them and
then we're gonna film them for like the
Internet that's pretty it's wild I
didn't know that's how they did that
well you know it just depends when
you're shooting but the point is you
don't have that much time with the topic
so it's like a you don't have time to
really try it out something it's
processing it been like trying to
working in the class for a while right
good practice and you mentioned putting
you look for the angles so what it what
do you mean by angles exactly the angles
just like the corona
you know before we got quarantine it's
like okay it's right something about it
was kind of a broad thing but right
something about the coronavirus and it's
like okay what are the angles like why
are we like I guess what I mean by
angles is like questions you're
questioning the topic okay how did we
get it why did we have it and so I came
up with a we have it because people told
us to get rid of straws people told us
to get rid of straws now we're putting
our mouths on everything and the turtles
are crying but now we all have the
coronavirus like or die huh
the angle is did the turtles care about
us we care about the turtles and now we
need help and the turtles don't give a
[ __ ] and it's like their heads they're
in their shells you know you know
there's more jokes about them being old
and then mumbling racial slurs in their
shells because they're a hundred so it's
like I guess what I need my angles is
like you're you're questioning the topic
you're asking questions let me close
this eye there's a light coming through
here yeah no problem like that yeah a
little a little backlight as they say so
thank you for everyone commenting with
questions as well and sticking with us
through this Internet debacle here
hopefully this data plan holds up so
yeah so the angles are the questions I
was following a train of thought there
you know because it's never dead on the
topic it's always like an ancillary
thing mm-hmm it's always like an it's
always say if it you know straight on
you have to if the angle it to be like
okay what's funny about this you know
and will you like right there usually
the little things it's usually the
little things that are money Oh
interesting okay like then like the
turtles saying the racial slur you mean
like little details like that is usually
what's the funny little details but it's
like how are we getting it what what you
know what would it prevented it and then
taking another like pop culture thing
that we just went through which is like
there was a whole big initiative before
started to get rid of straws so I
connected for the hole which people are
well aware of and everybody supported so
it's like get rid of straws like oh
maybe that caused it maybe the straw
people are the problem
gotcha see almost like here's a
pop-culture topic what are other
pop-culture topics I could maybe connect
it with and find that way to find an
angle yes it's a the problem is this and
the solution might also be out there
yeah you know what is the cylinder maybe
problem maybe vaping maybe another
problem is the solution you know oh
that's gold I love that and you'll just
write the topic like at the top of your
page and then just kind of start
brainstorming these things that's kind
of the the pen to paper process so it's
like okay I got to work on this on the
flight so it's like it helps to like
wreath and for me it helps to like read
the news and and go back to writing and
then read the news more because there's
angles in the news where it's like oh
this is happening this is happening this
is happening and then take it all into
consideration and be like okay one of
the angles of this joke one of the one
of the angles of the coronavirus what
are the angles of the quarantine you
know I mean yeah stuck together you know
everything is something else maybe
that's the angle you know it's like I
don't know I'm just sitting like you're
being playful with it you know you're
not settling on any one thing but it's
you it helps to talk it out but it also
if you can't talk it out if your ears
writing down maybe it on the full joke
but maybe in your quarantine it's your
own little Society so everything is
everything else the bathroom as a
hospital my closet is a gym my the other
room is a summer home you know to me
it's like you just you're you're being
playful with it it's like is that
something maybe that's not funny enough
you know it's like God keep playing with
it until I get it yeah I think it's
important
you take it to the next level where
you'll write it but then actually say it
with which then you almost have to start
justifying your words and I find a lot
of editing when I say things out loud
and you do you almost find the the big
punchline once you start saying it out
loud is that when you really start to
bring it to life the points but it's
like connecting the dots that just like
you have a few of the points out there
mhm and it's like it's like connecting
them you know I mean I think a funny way
to connect them you know or or you know
work concept like getting a concept down
and like playing with the concept until
you come up with the jokes
there's different ways I guess that's
two different ways of doing it finding
the finding the finding the points first
and then finding your way to the points
versus creating a concept and finding
finding the points afterwards and you
know that that makes sense
I make sense to me my head but maybe I'm
not explaining it I'm not explaining it
very well I don't think but it's just
the way my mind works it's like you know
if those are two ways of doing it coming
up a little concept and then right
finding the points locating the points
and then the concept to get into those
points yeah cuz I mean sometimes a joke
starts with oh I found almost the
punchline I need to work backwards on
how I get to it and other times it's
like well here's you take it all the way
from set up to punchline like sometimes
the joke is the in you start at the end
and then you have to work back in the
beginning and then work forward like
every joke kind of has its own
personality right it's like a deductive
process versus an inductive
and you had you have a dry race board
with your jokes or your joke ideas ideas
up yeah show us the goods okay so you
have like so I'll put the ideas off and
then and then and this is pre quarantine
obviously cuz I've but it's like put
them up and then okay there's something
there's a joke there there's a joke
there I don't know what the joke is but
there's something funny like going to
the dentist I went to the dentist before
you know the whole thang off your record
to the dentist and it's like I haven't
been able to come up with a good dentist
chunk there's a chunk there because a
lot of hilarious things happened I drove
about it but I haven't been able to like
solidly obviously now I can't because I
can't do comedy but I haven't been
solidly able to put it together but
there that's because it's it's I just
haven't been able to develop it but
there's a bunch of funny stuff there
uh-huh I can there's you know stuff like
when you go in they ask you for your
level of pain from one to ten that's
funny to me there's something there
that's like 1 to 10 could you rate your
own pain when you go into that I don't
have a joke for it but that's a
hilarious thing and I also went to the
NYU School of Dentistry where students
will work on your teeth oh and that's
funny
it's like yeah I have massive tooth pain
so what why not let a kid give it a shot
you know I mean I don't have there's
something funny about that so it's it's
like these little points writing them
down and then and then trying to it's
one of those things where it's an
instant critique there's something funny
there yeah I need to figure it out and
then once you get the joke it's like ok
I need to connect this to another
concept or thing that's funny yes I
think it's valuable especially younger
comics to be aware of that instinct and
really trust that instinct because even
someone
level is like there's something there I
don't know what yet but you're so honed
into your process that you know when
something's tapping at your brain of
like there's something here I just don't
know what yet that that's the direction
you need to go in and I think young
comics need to listen for that instinct
more and that will help them develop
well right actually that's really great
in terms of mindset when you have
something like that you have a point a
part of a part of the thing that might
become a joke and you're working it and
you know it's funny but you don't have
the joke yet your mindset in terms of
mindset should be it's on the way it's
on the way I love that I love that all
right yeah it's almost kind of like
manifesting it it's on the way it's
gonna be good I just have to figure out
how to get there you know awesome so
let's get into some more questions here
this one's uh Jason P Leonard and he
does all the the shows in Lafayette
Louisiana
he runs the Lafayette Comedy down there
and I said have you been down there have
you been to a Lafayette
done any of those shows now okay go
Jason come on man
this is well I guess now's not the time
to ask since we can't go anywhere but he
says so your last album the worst kind
of thoughtful which is a killer album
runs about an hour 20 minutes with
everyone generally shooting for 45 to 60
minutes for an album was there a reason
to go long or are you that happy with
the material I was looking to put out
all the material that I had hmm I was
just looking to put it all out I I
wanted to get it documented and out so
that I'd have to because I'm gonna turn
it over I know I'm going to turn it over
so and I'm gonna move forward in order
to do that I don't want to lose any of
it so I could
probably de Cobo album I think I had
enough to do a double album but I just
chose to put it all on one thing and
just give it to like Sirius XM and let
them play it and so that was my mind my
mindset was just getting the material
out getting it documented and moving on
in retrospect I should have shot it I
should have shot it also but 2008 things
are moving fast and no one was putting
out the clips like they are now so what
I should have done is shot it and then
put it out on Sirius XM and then release
the clips and incrementally is what I
should have done is that what you're
fine doing over again what I would do
but the whole goal to answer the
question yeah was to get the material
documented get it out and get it making
some money for me which was on Sirius
which you're getting residuals from that
were like the best way to get money on
it yeah how I find that's and I hear
that's how comics make mostly their
money is through those residuals like
sales or anything like that like did you
find any useful ways to actually market
the album that you're able to get drive
sales of it just getting podcast was a
good way of letting people know about it
and then having other comics vouch for
the album nice guys with who were
respected and guys with bigger
followings to be like you gotta check
this guy's out and a lot of my good
friends did that for me
you know Ari Shaffir was to go Bert
Kreischer did it Dave Attell people that
I respect and looked up to Jay oakerson
Dan Soder those guys all like promoted
it and say yeah this guy's got a really
good album I not know who you know you
might not know him like comics know him
so listen to his album and I've gotten a
lot of positive feedback and a lot of
people buying the album because of it
do now have like an another hour like
how quickly do you turn over material
yeah I'm not I mean I've seen the other
guys doing it they're doing it faster
than I am I need a little bit more time
that Louie
doing it Louie and burr like they were
doing once a year like every year and
that's Tamizh
I can't do it that yeah I mean that's
yeah those in 2018 doesn't H Dean and uh
I know I was on a pretty good pace
turning it over I'm not sure really
where I was my mindset is I'd rather be
over-prepared so it takes a few years
I'd rather be over-prepared than then
the material for me getting halfway
there and being like okay I'm gonna put
this out I'd rather be over prepared for
it so I'd rather have an hour 20 and I'd
be forced to cut it to an hour versus
you know no straining to get that hour
or been things not being tight enough
because we can all tell the level of
glass that we're getting any audience
it's like oh that's getting some kind of
a laugh but it's not getting the deep
got laugh that I need so it's like it
could be funnier or if it's getting that
kind of a laugh maybe that's a jab into
something stronger you know I can't just
leave that I can't just leave that at
that level of laughter it's not it's not
usable for me unless it's to get into
something else that's much funnier what
do you find provokes that gut laughter
that we all like seek what have you
found is there like a specific type of
joke or like is it the more personal
material like what what gets the
audience in the gut like that guys do it
with emotion I've seen it I've seen guys
do like different kinds where people go
yeah I've been in that situation before
and that's a hilarious cake and it's
hilarious because they've gone through
they've gone through the same thing and
then the comic is taking such a twist on
it and it's it hurts there they're
taking their past thoughts and behavior
and then they're listening to this guy
spin on it and it's and it makes them
laugh it's a man it's making them got
laugh because they've been in that
situation they've never thought of it
that way so it's something familiar and
that they can connect to and then the
turn on it that the cons unique take on
it really affects them and if
unlike in an emotional way okay and then
I've seen guys do it with straight I see
you guys do it with straight jokes just
like just kale with straight jokes also
so you know I guess there's multiple
there's multiple ways of getting that
gut laugh but the important thing is
like recognizing it
recognizing just do you do your style of
what you're doing but then recognizing
when it's a gut laughing and recognizing
when people are just laughing or what
what the level of it is is its
importance important yeah not party
enough and listening to the audience
like you've I feel like the first few
years of comedy or maybe several years
is like you're just worried about your
words and what you're saying but then
you start to develop a new awareness
when you actually start listening to the
audience and you instead of focusing on
what you're saying it's almost like how
are they responding you could start to
take real-life data from each joke but
listening to the audience is like a
whole other skill set yeah
listening to listening to them and
listening to the level of which the
level at which they're affecting them
hmm and and and it's like abroad it's
kind of a thing over time because you'll
get some dum dum audiences so you know
and you can't totally discount them but
you can't give them the weight that you
would give an audience that's good
gotcha so let's let's get into the next
one he write me because it'll ruin you
know it'll discourage the joke it might
be a good joke and it might be it but
the audience might not be too dumb to
get it so but that doesn't mean that the
joke is bad it means that maybe the joke
needs some work or maybe the audience
isn't connecting to it for some reason
that's that's their problem and not
yours you Sean Penn said that something
has to be taken any consideration I
think and you'll develop you develop a
stronger sense of yourself over time as
the years pass of doing it you go
because there'll be audiences
they'll be audiences that are not good
and you might get a few of them in a row
on a weekend and it's almost like you're
trying to muscle you out of your jokes
and you're like no that's not you're not
right no we're not right no I'm right
but you don't get that into length later
like you know in your career like later
on I would you know you don't have that
muscle to be like no you're not because
they can they're the danger in that is
that they're perfectly capable of
talking you out of a very good joke how
do you know when you're getting talked
out of a good joke and when the joke
just isn't good yeah that's that's the
trick the trick is like having the
experience over the years to be like no
there's something about this that's
that's funny it's not working here but
but I guess talking it out with friends
other comics and then and then trying it
in different environments is the cave's
trying it over time the food with
different audiences gotcha and I guess
trusting that like we said with the
writing and you think there's something
there if you think there's something
there then it's gonna be worth the time
and pain onstage to get it to a place to
where it's working yeah this is not
working with any audience and you can't
be delusional and go no these people are
too stupid it's like everybody's not
stupid so it's like you need to fix the
joke there's people who will do this
guys who will do that - you're just not
getting me it's like no one is getting
it's not funny it's not funny
you know and I'll be first got to do
that to myself so it's like but you have
to be aware of it - like you have to be
aware of it like he's just not good
enough I mean at the end of the day it's
not so I have to fix it
how many excited get rid of it yeah how
many times will you do a joke before
you're like yeah never mind I hire
weekends were where I'll be struggling
with the ah rubbish strut I'll be
fighting them and I'll go although
that's not me it's not
I shouldn't have to fight this hard with
them hmm with the audio shouldn't have
to fight this on though it's like and
then then it's like I can work them and
I'll try in whatever but as far as
giving them me giving them the credit
for me placing a lot of weight on their
response that kind of phase like I'm
like I can't I can't I can't give them
it's like the crowd has to earn it
you know I mean - I have to earn it with
them but they have to earn it with me as
far as like knowing what's funny and
what's knowing what's funny and if they
if too many too many jokes like hit them
in the head and bounce off and they're
not getting them their credibility is
ruined as far as me developing new
material me like listening them to them
to develop new material their
credibility gets shot gotcha because I'm
hitting them with proven jokes and
they're like either giving it nothing or
like not responding in a way where it's
like I'm pulling it out of them then
they're probably credibility is shot and
I won't place much weight on them when
I'm trying a new job but when you're
trying a new joke how many shows will
you give it a run before you think I
need to shelf this yeah it's not a
number of shows it's also like if you're
in one place and you're doing five shows
and you're struggling with your good
jokes when every audience I'm not giving
them I'm not trying new material there
to give them I'm not gonna expose myself
my new material to them so that they can
shoot it down they're already not giving
the stuff that's good that's already
proven they're not giving Maddie mm-hmm
oh they're credibility it's gone so I'll
give it a whole nother I'll give it a
whole nother set of shows gotcha to
other audiences other places and then
I'll get I need to get an objective read
on it and I can't do that if people are
morons
or they have a bad day or they're
looking at me like oh you think you're
better than me like you know you get the
vibes from the audience and it's like I
don't know what you're doing like I
don't know what you're doing but I'm
trying to help you to have a good time
and I'm I
know how to do that in the moment like I
know how to figure not to get them and
pull them in but as far as trying new
material goes I can't give them the
credibility I can't give them an read
ability yeah so this actually I don't
know if that makes any sense
will you takes and take the feedback I
might be explaining it wrong
I think it makes sense me you're pretty
much just saying whenever you do a show
you take the feedback with the grain of
salt of what this audience is like what
what all are they laughing at so maybe
they're not laughing at my killer
material then this newer joke I'm not
getting a good read on it because
they're not even reading when the
material is good or not to begin with so
it's like you you take your the audience
feedback based on their overall like you
almost like grade the audience like
whether or not it's worth getting the
feedback or not or this audience is okay
they laughed at certain things but not
others the thing is that they're not if
the proven jokes are not going well with
the proven jokes then then it's not
going to be a good read on new material
yeah that's basically what I'm trying to
say so I don't know who this next person
their name didn't show up but they did
ask are you optimistic about live shows
returning in the foreseeable future I'd
like to think so but I just don't know I
don't right now as it stands like I do
not see I see people maybe going back to
her work right now but as far as like
gathering in small areas for comedy like
III don't know like hopefully like a
vaccination or some kind of a medication
comes out but I just don't know enough
that's gonna happen at anytime soon yeah
it's crazy too and it's it's interesting
to see like keeping a comedy centric
just all what all comedians are trying
to like how we're trying to even figure
out what to do
you right now a lot of it you know it's
just it's unknown everybody's trying to
figure it out yeah ed stuff it's very
tough okay no you're that light's
killing them so here's this one plate
this was talked about live shows also
it's a Gus Horne Perea harira I am doing
great with names sorry thanks for
commenting everyone
Gus horn says Mike saw you opening for
Myron Lefkowitz in February oh yeah were
you guys at all afraid something would
happen due to the circumstances I wasn't
afraid really I just I got a good I got
a good feeling like because it was those
were midnight shows so when people were
filing in I got like a good vibe so I
didn't think they were being crazy
business why is he asking this what what
was going on there I don't even know who
my Rijn Lefkowitz is what's the song it
was there was Ari chose oh I see I
didn't know Myron Lefkowitz was also Ari
Shaffir have you have you seen him since
his his situation have you have you have
hung out with him oh this so this was
after the Kobe situation I guess oh wow
okay yeah oh yeah that's why he was
asking it was he's asking if it was a
dangerous situation and how did you feel
about the situation being made
potentially dangerous and I guess that
was is a possibility yeah but uh it was
it went and and then unless I'm it
unless
good how did how did he respond to all
this like when you got did you ever have
even ask him about the situation or
anything nah I know I just I I know I I
understand people people why people work
that I understand it and but I
understand his mindset of what he was
doing I understand it so I understand
both sides of it yeah I understand but I
understand people's response and
reaction now threatening violence and
all that stuff it's like kinda it's out
of balance you know
but I understand the response to it in
the moment but I I did understand what
he was trying to do and I'm more than
that any more than any of that like i
friends with Ari I like him very much so
I called him just personal and not
posting anything like I'm not a big post
stuff about like whatever situations but
I did call him I called him - - or text
I texted him I think to make sure he was
okay
and you know he was mentally doing okay
there's something about regardless of
the situation when we're living at the
time now where it's like when the world
turns on you whether it's justified or
not whether the when the world like
Twitter like oh it's a when the world
turns on you
like I said justified or not it can it
can mess with your mic and screw your
mind up you know so he's a friend of
mine so I did reach out to him to make
sure he was okay mentally you know was
he okay mentally like he was doing all
right with the whole thing yeah he
responded but he responded with his hope
so he responded back with a joke Wow I
know he was I know it's taxing it's
taxing on oh my god that would be taxing
on anybody like and like I'm saying
regardless regardless if you right or
wrong it's it's it's or whether you
brought it on yourself or whatever the
situation is it's a lot of mental stress
I would have I would imagine I put
myself in that position and even if I
created the situation for myself I would
have mad
Chennai would be under a lot of mental
stress there yeah that's what was
bizarre about it when you hear other
comics talk about that situation was
it's like I mean I know they're like I
know Ari he's the nicest guy ever and
this rose right he's the that's all I
hear about him like I've never met him
or anything but I hear he's literally
like the nicest guy but this joke just
he's kind of missed he was doing it with
every other so it's a it's a dangerous
road to go down anyway it's a risky
you're you're walking a tight walk
tightrope anyway right you don't mean
but he was doing with previous
celebrities and people were like well
there was no joke there and and and I
understand that I do understand it but
the whole thing is a joke
lady get out of me and like it's like oh
there's no joke in there it's like I
understand that I understand why you
could say that and that's true
but that's from my understanding the
jokes not in there because the entire
thing is a joke hmm okay Franklin he did
it with the 90210 guy he did it with Tom
Petty like all these things so and then
he was just doing it again but you know
he didn't take a couple of things into
consideration and it backfired so you
know yeah but but I understand I
understand the reaction I do understand
it but I also understand what them
people go what's the mind I don't
understand the mindset so but in looking
at if you look at the history of what he
was doing
yeah and then look at the you'll see the
totality of it and that's a different
thing what do you think it's funny or
not right that's not funny no matter
what I understand that I I completely
get that and you have to write that you
know so it's just a matter of that but
the bottom line is he's a friend of mine
I love them and
when that happened regardless of what
you feel about the situation I didn't
reach out to him to make sure he was
okay yeah and I guess there hasn't
really been any violence I know that's
what Gus was asking the circumstances
there were threats but I guess nothing's
I don't know people I don't know a
short-term memory as well I guess in
terms of people like that's crazy and
then like a week later on to something
else that's crazy as well but that one
that one was like yeah I do understand
why people are upset yeah now now death
threats and all that stuff is like
that's you know that's beyond you know
you should never put anybody's life you
know at risk so but the shows did go
well the show went very well great so
you yeah if you worked with them did you
guys come up together like up in the net
so that's what it's like he was in LA
and doing great and he was like no no
I'm gonna I think I never talked about
but I think his mindset was now I'm
gonna experience something different I
wanna you know New York just because the
number of rooms and the opportunities to
get on stage it's like more conducive to
stand up so he he moved down here he
moved out here and then when I think
he's still going back and forth
bicoastal but he spends a lot of time
and and and grind grinds in these clubs
in order to get better so I really like
that about him this actually ties in to
Sasha's question as well talking about
clubs Sasha
Nicholas asked what are some of your
favorite clubs to perform at that aren't
the main ones like the cellar Comedy
Store etc and what are your favorite
smaller cities you performed in I
haven't really been in the south that
much so looking forward someday going
it's going to the south
I don't think things are as divided as
people
would think or it used to be because the
internet we're all watching the same
things we're all connected so it's like
when you go oh you people from down here
in the South don't understand like
everybody understands everything because
of the internet now so you know but um I
really like performing in Minnesota
that's a great like I think the people
they are really good
I do the Mall of America Ronson's house
of comedy and I really like that but I
do I'd be gone there for years and I
love that I like the people there you
know I really because people come from
all over the place that Acme comedy on
state and Wisconsin is great the DCM
promise is a great place you know and
the the areas are good but it's also it
also depends what kind of Club it is if
it's a good club the club is well run
then the clientele that comes in will be
better regardless of the area yep yeah
yeah I've heard great things about
comedy on state and the the Minnesota
one was it is that the Acme one is that
Acme or is that now is that min
Annapolis oscillate
okay the house okay yeah that's right
you said Rick Bronson's house of comedy
okay
nice big rant like the stress factory
stress factory in New Brunswick New
Jersey and the one in Bridgeport
Connecticut there's two he is two of
them now those are very good no no you
didn't say any comedy zones there you
don't like doing if you ever done
comedies okay that's what I had been I
had started to do more of those last
year I was starting to get some more
work thrown at me from that angle in
terms of getting more Road gigs like
that which some are some are better than
others you know regardless the money is
never great but right I guess that's a
part of it you know I'm I just hit my
ten-year
so I've been and last year was really my
big step into headlining more and like
getting on stage for that 45 minutes and
really have any like establish and
sustain yourself on stage so getting do
comedy zones and performing around
outside of my immediate area was it's
been a good learning experience both on
stage but then also from the business
side you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
for sure oh this is a this is a good one
here no Ryan MacGuffin asks and this
guy's actually been on hot breath he's
awesome
Ryan mcgucket asks how has Nick Griffin
not blown up yet that's a really good
question
because he is he's a friend of mine and
he's uh he's great man he's a great
comic so yeah stuff like that terrifies
me
how he has he deserves to be much bigger
than he is I believe and Nick is one of
the best I think it's one of the best
what do you mean it terrifies you what
terrifies you about it
well it terrifies me because I mean I
don't know he shouldn't be flying under
the radar like he should be he has a
certain level of success like he's way
funnier like he's he should be at he
should be more commercially successful I
believe has he's my friend yeah but
anybody who wants him it's it's it's all
it's built from the ground up that guy's
he's built from the ground up so it's
solid great joke writing and that's what
I'm for
none more anybody you know nice and he's
personally my friend but I'm for anybody
doing that I root for those guys the
guys who build it from the ground up but
people could
not to the degree of like Nick but I
feel like people could also say that to
degree about like a tell where I mean
he's big and he sells out wherever he
goes but I feel like he could and should
be like even bigger if that makes sense
like I mean I'm not I'm not knocking his
career at all but I feel like he could
and should be doing more like theaters
or something like he's every every
comedians like he's the funniest he's
the funniest like hands-down you know
he's he's the greatest but yet outside
of maybe his immediate family
that's being recognized or do you not
agree I mean you're friends with him so
I don't know no I it's the difference
between commercially what's what people
think is great and what what up other
people say I don't know I think if you
see it you want if you watch any of what
he's doing
you oughta Manuel come out no matter who
you are you'll come out with the same
opinion but that all of us have which is
he's the best guy so I don't understand
you know there doesn't need to be like
either him or Nick really there doesn't
me I don't understand it from a
standpoint of like I don't understand
why there needs to be a huge marketing
push for these guys there doesn't all
you have to do is watch it all you have
to do is actually watch it and if you
watch it if you're not walking away with
the same like this guy is the bass guy
then I don't know I don't know what to
tell you and this so I don't know put
this short the short end is I don't have
an answer I don't know I don't think it
I think it's as simple just watching it
but apparently that's not maybe it's
it's my lack of understanding of people
I think it's my lack of understanding of
like common people mm-hmm or business I
mean cuz there's it's show business so
it's like you know the show is the job
then the business is also like another
job and some people are better that one
than the other
and it's a it's like a it's a balancing
act you have to kind of like nurture
those things where it's like it's one of
those things it's like somebody sells
you a pad or something and they go this
is the best bed ever and it's like uh
nationally marketing it's the McDonald's
of beds everybody has everybody knows it
and whatever and it's it's fine but then
like a small like a company introduces a
better bed and you've slept on it and
it's it's many times better than the
McDonald's bed it is many times but it's
like it's not advertised everywhere and
it's not in your face everywhere it's
just but it is built mmm much better and
it is a much better bet so it's like
which one do you choose well you know if
all you know is the McDonald's bed then
you're just gonna choose that because
it's the thing that everybody is but if
you if you've tried the other bed and
you still go back to the McDonald's bed
I don't know what to tell you gotcha
yeah that's just that's the nature of
comedy I guess so but some people blow
up and then others I don't know like
some people all different people stick
people at different tastes people have
different tastes people have different
things that make them tick I guess you
know I don't know I don't personally
understand people also have different
aspirations so it's not like every
comedian we're like they're hilarious
they should be where we think they
should be I mean we may see a comedian
they're like happy where they are
they're like no this is where I wanted
to to be you know so it's also a
difference in taste of each comedian and
what their goals and aspirations are as
well so I don't need to project they
need to be somewhere we think they
should be it's like I mean if they're
happy with where they are that's also
something to be noted now it's not even
that it's not even like where they are
their aspiration it's it's it's about
I'd be interested to see that and that
would be a good experiment like a folk
group we're a focus group watches one
comedian and then a focus group watches
another comedian and then I can sit
there and watch them talk about it that
would be great for me because I'm I have
a lack of understanding I just have a
lack of understanding
so that's found anything yeah that would
actually be very helpful a focus group
watching a comedian that I don't think
is any good and then have been talking
about it and and and to see you know and
to see why they think that a comic who I
don't think is very skilled but it's
commercially successful huh and then
have them talk about it and then me
watch it what and where we talk about
aspirations like what are what are your
aspirations like what are you hoping to
kind of achieve or Excel through your
career now commercial success I would
really like that
[Music]
oh okay right yeah I thought you were
talking to your commercially successful
so if you're like hello commercially
successful self I'm speaking to you in
to exist like hilarious yeah and Ryan
says the same thing that happened with
music garbage is on the radio ah yeah I
mean this commercial yeah the side but
like to you what is commercial now what
do you owe is there a category like I
would like everything on I would like
more commercial success but I also like
different opportunities like I would
like to be on a show I'm acting I would
like my podcast to be what it is but
even more great or reach more people
oh my comedy to you know reach more
people basically okay
nice and this this could be a good one
to wrap it up with as we're speaking
about comedians skip actually chimed in
with is there a comedian you feel
everyone should be watching out for I
think there's a bunch here man I'm privy
to New York so I think there's a bunch
of guys here that people should keep
their eye on and should be watching I
think all you have to do is like go to
the clubs if you go to the clubs here
you'll see guys who are really good and
and not even the club's it's a even if
you go to rooms here you may see people
who again like they're not in the clubs
they're flying under the radar because
they're in rooms and for whatever reason
they can't get into the clubs and
they're very good so it's like the
people who are like working on their
craft everything it's not like a mystery
it's like the people who are in it and
working on their craft every single
night and on the road and striving to
approve those guys in my opinion are the
guys that are good and and and you can
watch somebody and and you could we can
all like watch people and we know what
skill level they're at we know if
they're doing it so um that's where it's
at for me those are the guys who are
real for me names you have any names
enemy names I think the guys that are
like guys and girls that are under the
radar not under the radar they had some
TV success but like are in the clubs and
deserve more recognition I think Harmon
Lynch is one Adrian a pallucci my
girlfriend Katie Hannigan is very funny
I think Gary leader it is very funny
Greg stone Anthony DeVito these guys are
like probably I don't know how many
years in ten twelve you know right maybe
13 14 something like that or maybe
Harmons been in a little bit longer so
it's like I'm trying to think of people
who are not like household name
or those guys are like in the clubs but
under the radar
you know in New York working and they're
very funny
you know like mark Normand has a
obviously has a level of commercial
success now he's doing well and I'm
happy for mark is in front of my Sam
arel with his special yeah those guys
weren't already kind of like making a
name for themselves in and they're out
there but there's a there's a lot of
people who are you know in the club's
under the radar and those those are the
people who are you know before the
epidemic like they were working hard you
know keeping I'm a big fan of like nose
to the grindstone you know right
creating creating material you know so
this yeah a lot of the the people that
listen to this are comics specifically
comics out there grinding more people
like me like 10 years in or even younger
where it's more just like starting out
maybe they've only done it like a few
times I mean do you have any closing
advice or any comedy wisdom that has
become your favorite because you're
around in New York I mean you're you
know you're hanging out with the best of
the best so is there anything you've
absorbed that you could maybe share with
us before we get out of here I don't
think I'm gonna share anything new like
the strategies that I employ are I'm out
clubs every night no most every night I
take a couple nights off just ER you
know before this all happened
the quarantine you know a couple nights
to like rejuvenate and so like
self-care you know if they'll work out
and just kind of like be off the road
and not on the clothes but every other
night in the club's working podcasting
and podcasts also was the thing where I
thought oh I was like I don't know what
this is like just talking but you can
make it whatever you want to make it
it's really you know you don't have to
like just go by what everybody else is
doing you could turn it into whatever
you want to turn it into so it's sounds
corny but just the general thing is just
try the best you can in all aspects you
know just keep trying the best that you
can watch people Journal they different
strategies you can employ but follow
through with them and and you know keep
trying to get better that's a major
thing it sounds like a general note but
keep trying to get better yeah it sounds
like it's you're saying do the work you
know I mean take this seriously and do
the necessary work a lot of people don't
want to do the work do the work and take
the mindset into it like I'm going to
get better I'm going to get better make
your mindset into the work you know it
helps beautiful well Mike this is thank
you so much for doing this man you've
been one of my favorite guests and so
many people reached out after your first
interview with us about just how much
they learned so I knew this was going to
be a good one
I'm glad the internet held up I think it
created a little bit of a delay me going
on data but it was well worth using my
data plan to make this thing happen dude
this was awesome I appreciate you taking
the time to do it seriously no problem
all right hop Brett the verse that is
Mike Becky own where can they like
support you check out anything you have
going on as well my podcast is called no
disrespect anywhere where you get
podcasts it's called no disrespect me
myself Justin silver and Shannon Lee and
I that's where you can access me if you
again social media a comic like they my
album is also called the worst kind of
[ __ ] yeah iTunes yes yes go go check
that out
support comedians doing the the good
work of comedy this guy's one of the
funniest out there and I feel it we're
gonna look back on this and people that
were involved in this gonna be like I
can't believe I got that
immediate access to Mike Vecchio I'm
really excited for everything you're
working towards and it's cool almost
that you didn't record this album
because that's still like that's still
something you get to do you know what I
mean in terms of like having a special
right and all that like because it's
only a matter of time man like it's just
yeah so I mean I mean I'm almost excited
that it didn't happen then because now
it's just you're just gonna keep getting
better and better than when that drops
it's just it's very exciting I'm a big
fan Mike I'm a big fan no doubt buddy
stay safe out there hey hot brother and
sister if you love comedy as much as we
do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips